[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy friday
thanks for joining us here on let's
hockey tony michaels podcast every
single weekday
[Music]
big news yesterday
big huge news and it's already dropped
off the twitter trends this just shows
you
this just shows you how [ __ ]
ridiculous these new cycles are
because today today uh hillary clinton
needs to go to prison of course is
trending because they have to distract
from the orange mussolini jesus being
deposed in the civil case uh where the
state of new york and tish james the
attorney general
is going to go after the trump
organization and probably cut it down
like a brush cut tree
that is what's happening
uh it looks like uh ivanka and don
junior are gonna have to be deposed just
like eric trump was you guys seen we had
eric trump on last week i'm talking
about his a little bit about his
deposition because he was whining like a
little [ __ ] on sean hannity's show you
guys remember the sean hannity freak out
that eric had
um
and uh he came on the show to respond of
course eric trump made it on the
bonehead of the week and it's friday
it's friday so you know what that means
we're gonna do
the bonehead of the week in the second
hour the first hour we'll do the [ __ ]
list roundup
and the second hour we'll do bonehead of
the week with gabe um someone is also
going to be joining us uh
sometime at 9 30.
we have a
a special guest
uh going to join us at 9 30 it seems i
don't know much about the guest if that
gives you a hint of
what is about to
happen here and you know i i never i
never know some of these guests that are
going to show up like last week i had no
idea
what was going to happen when eric trump
showed up on the show
we've had twitter tech support before
we've had pastor brian
we've had uh heidi cruz show up so we've
had a lot of special guests so uh
surprise i say not special surprise
guest
surprise it's a big surprise so maybe
we'll have maybe we'll have a uh
a surprise guest at the bottom of this
hour at the bottom of this hour so
12 30 eastern 9 30 pacific
would be the time that possibly some
surprise guest shows up
but in the meantime we got to go through
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
of today because we gotta we gotta round
up all the news all the [ __ ] list
because we when we get into the second
hour we're going to do bonehead of the
week
we like bonehead of the week here we
like the poll
if you want to vote in the poll the
bonehead of the week poll every week
just go to tonymichaelspod
on twitter you can follow me the tony
michaels and i am gabe sanchez follow us
both but also follow the pod because
that's where you'll find the bonehead of
the week poll which we'll go through
today
so all of you out there listening
if you want to vote and you should vote
go [ __ ] vote you should vote anytime
you have a chance whether it be whether
it be for a pro-democracy candidate
or just to show your support to um clown
these [ __ ] because that's what
we do here is clown these son of a
[ __ ]
we clown them which there's a lot of
clowning to do today the the trouble is
the tweety treats and the trendy trends
the the trump seemed to drop off very
quickly
everyone was raking them through the
coals last night but of course uh
overnight with the russian russia being
awake
um they got a hillary hashtag trending
of course
when when a certain group of people are
awake around the world and the americans
are asleep
the the russian bot farms get a hashtag
trending because they're terrified
terrified that the trumps are going down
because there's no telling what we'll
find out i believe that's the truth
who's here this morning hello everybody
hello robin hello anne hello patty
hello everyone everyone everyone this
morning is joining us
thank you for joining us
let's see let's go to the i want to go
to my profile here
um the timeline before we start the
shitless roundup
um
dude come on
there we go
uh
there was um
something i wanted to show i can't even
remember now well maybe we'll just uh
welcome mj mj's here everybody welcome
mj oh there's there's a lot of good
trump videos to show there's a lot of
good trump videos so so let's do this
let's do this let's start the [ __ ] list
roundup we round up the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
and then we'll get to our
surprise guest at the bottom of the hour
and then to
bonehead of the week let's start the
countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome to the shitless
roundup we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends of the day
on the tony michaels podcast
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central we have we have some news last
night uh about the fifth amendment and
the reason why we have the fifth
amendment trending last night is because
tis james won her case the judge in york
said no you have to be deposed you can't
get out of this you have no special
privileges uh donald trump's lawyers
tried to
make it sound like he was in a special
class of people
if if you're not aware if you're not
aware what fascism is and when fascists
know don't even know their fascist it's
when they go to court and say we're
above the law no we're in a different
class of people i have a different type
of privilege than everyone else
um you know i'm superior to anyone even
in the law i'm superior
it's fascism folks
it's fascism they might not know that
that's what it is but that's what it is
so let's go back to last week when eric
trump was here we know that era trump is
the uh
the bonehead of the week
uh as you know so we'll go through that
but let's look at the clip from last
week when he was here let's make this a
little bigger it's very important this
is very important stuff
that we see this sir you is this eric
trump are you eric trump are you here to
respond
yes i don't like the way that everyone
is talking about me and my father what
what's wrong eric are you
why why are you so upset
am i under oath you're you're on a
podcast you're not under oath but you
are live i played the fifth
the fifth
do you know what the fifth is
it's the first amendment
plus two second amendments you're like
leticia james i didn't get the answer
that i wanted tell me the answer answer
my questions answer my questions what
you said last night on the hannity show
you know a lot of people on twitter are
really raking you through the coals here
they're calling you you know whiny
little [ __ ] and stuff is there anything
you'd like to tell the people out there
on twitter
he was like oh man
hunter biden gets actual love from his
father
not like us
what do you think about the videos that
yet your brother does
have you ever considered doing these
videos i'm usually in the room and i'm
the one directing and i'm like okay
eyes up
open eyes open
open your eyes
so
i'm there i'm like i'm like a real
hollywood director but then i find out
later that i find out my dad's also
going to pee go make some confetti go
get some coffee
oh really so you became confetti coffee
boy at that point when them yeah and
here's the thing spoiler that's where
kofi comes from
eric i i really do appreciate you coming
on and um you know giving us all this
information i'm sure it'll be very
valuable to prosecutors um that are
looking into you your father and your
family business wait wait no you said
you said this wasn't on the record
so eric trump joined us last week as you
know i actually i think that was on
monday wasn't that
[ __ ] i don't remember it's hard to
remember when and where these things
happen it really is on this show you do
it every day two hours a day it's hard
to remember you go through this news
cycle this five second news cycle it's
hard to keep track i mean really
honestly we're in a situation where this
isn't even trending anymore
is this eric trump it's not even
trending anymore i i wrote ivanka don jr
brushing up on the fifth amendment eric
trump knows a thing or fifth
not a thing or two a thing or fifth
about it um here is the uh report from
msnbc when it broke yesterday um
here's hallie jackson we'll come back to
you but we've got to get in in just the
last couple of minutes some developing
news that's just happened we've been
talking about the new york attorney
general leticia james in court today and
the judge's ruling is now in
that new york judge ruling former
president trump will be forced to
testify
in that civil suit against the trump
organization lawyers for former
president trump remember wanted to block
the subpoena that is what the the
arguments the discussion was today well
now again we're hearing from this judge
the former president's got to testify
keep in mind things he says in this
civil hearing could be used in other
lawsuits including potentially other
investigations like the manhattan d.a
criminal case against the trump
organization i want to bring in nbc news
correspondent tom winner so tom bring us
up to speed 309 in the afternoon we knew
the judge was going to make a decision
by three and that sure happened that's
exactly right hallie so the judge arthur
engeron uh issuing a ruling here just in
the last several minutes what the trumps
had wanted is either for these
depositions to go away or in lieu of
that for them to be stayed until the
criminal investigation that you
reference is concluded the judge has
denied that on both counts the key graph
here saying in the final analysis the
state attorney general commences
investigating a business entity uncovers
copious evidence of possible financial
fraud and wants to question under oath
several of the entities principles
including its namesake she has the clear
right to do so so an unequivocal
shutdown of the trump's arguments today
uh that means that the trump's uh the
former president as well is ivanka and
don jr will need to sit for a civil
deposition they have the opportunity of
course to appeal
uh this this ruling today uh to i
believe the state supreme court but i
want to triple check that um and have
the opportunity to uh to see if they can
uh uh press this up or at least stay uh
today's ruling um
what has been determined here by the
judge is that within 14 days of this
order
um
trump will i'm just reading it real time
so just excuse me so here's the thing so
if they if you know we've said this
before and over and over and over again
this is [ __ ] absolutely ridiculous
that we have to continue to do this [ __ ]
about these [ __ ] criminals this
[ __ ] crime family they think they're
[ __ ] mobsters and [ __ ]
they're they're a protected class of
citizen they're fascists these
[ __ ] and the reason why we have
to keep doing this stupid [ __ ] is
because they have [ __ ] to hide
if they didn't have anything to [ __ ]
hide if it wasn't such a big [ __ ]
deal if they didn't do anything wrong if
they could prove beyond a shadow of a
doubt in a deposition that hey there
might have been some accounting errors
fine but they don't the reason why they
don't want to be deposed because they're
[ __ ] criminals
and they know when they get to pose that
their [ __ ] organization is gonna
[ __ ] get cut off at the kneecaps here
tis james destroyed their charitable
foundation destroyed their university
and is about to destroy their [ __ ]
entire money laundering machine that's
what they're terrified of these
[ __ ] that's why they're running
the true social game the pump and dump
where they're charging they're charging
their [ __ ] stupid-ass supporters 4.99
a week for something that doesn't even
exist yet
it's just a screenshot on twitter get
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
and i cannot believe i cannot believe
that we still have people in this
country that take this [ __ ]
seriously here's a guy who [ __ ] up the
entire goddamn country couldn't
lost by 8 million [ __ ] votes
eight
81 million people didn't vote for biden
there's a a large majority of that 81
million people that voted against trump
and i would imagine that there's a hell
of a lot more after january 6 happened
that would vote against this
[ __ ] fascist
but here you have the cfo of his of his
organization who is criminally charged
and his organization is criminally
charged in a case in the manhattan da's
office for fraud [ __ ] fraud tax fraud
which there's surely to be tax fraud not
just on his state tax returns but also
on his federal ones which the manhattan
d.a has so you think that they're
probably going to give criminal
referrals to the [ __ ] feds
and you have tis james wanting to depose
these people in a civil case against
against the the trump organization who
is defrauding the state of new york they
just want their [ __ ] money that's
owed to him
and we have people
who still support this [ __ ] who
stood on stage and said well if you
plead the fifth you must have something
to hide and here they are they won't
even sit down for depositions because
here's the rub here's the rub
trump's attorneys know that he won't
plead the fifth eric trump don jr and
ivanka they'll plead the fifth all day
[ __ ] long but donald trump the cheeto
dust mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
thinks he's in a protected class he's
above everyone he's above the law and
he's superior to you and anyone else and
anyone who would question him at all
and he thinks that his little slick
tongue is gonna get him out of
everything you see it in any interview
that he does
any time that he speaks
so he ain't gonna plea the fifth he's
gonna talk and yap and [ __ ] meander
on and on and on
and getting all kinds of trouble here
that's why he knows he doesn't want to
go in for deposition because he can't
keep his [ __ ] trap shut
he can't do it it's not manageable for
that [ __ ]
so
i'm excited to see
that tisch james is winning this case
and she'll continue to win these appeals
there's no way that this protected class
of citizen [ __ ] is gonna work in front
of a in front of a [ __ ] judge that
you're a protected class of citizen that
you're above the law a ch
good luck with that you dumb
[ __ ]
and all the while their accounting firm
mizars has [ __ ] abandoned them
they've joined the prosecution there's
two
there's two sides to every case whether
it's civil or criminal whichever one
you're talking about rather it's that
the case that tish james the attorney
general of the state of new york is
bringing against a trump organization in
a civil lawsuit to try to make sure that
they get the money they're owed that
they were defrauded
or
if it's the criminal case in the
manhattan da's office
or any federal case that may be referred
from those two investigations that are
currently going on
mizars has said the accounting firm that
has been with them for over a decade
has retracted
retracted over a decade's worth of
accounting records and even said in a
statement
in basic terms hey we went off the
fraudulent information that you gave us
and now we know it's fraud so we're
retracting it
and by the way
by the way
we're going to join the prosecution side
that's the most significant thing is
mizar's here has not joined the defense
side of the argument there's only two
arguments in a court only two
you don't get to have a [ __ ] in
between there's no in between you're
either on the prosecution side or the
defense that's how it works
whether it's just or not that's how it
[ __ ] works and you don't get the
claim that you're a protected class of
citizen
just because you used to be the
president of the united states
and i'm sure that the judges in the
state of new york don't give two flying
[ __ ] if this guy used to be president
or not or tries to make the case that
he's a protected class of citizen this
is [ __ ] fascist [ __ ] 101
fascist [ __ ] 101.
i would say i would say
if i were giving if i were an attorney
which i'm not but if i were an attorney
for ivanka or don jr even eric that dumb
[ __ ]
if i was their lawyer i'd say hey it's
time to join the prosecution here
it's time to join the prosecution
it's time to join the prosecution [ __ ]
these [ __ ] [ __ ] these [ __ ] and
we're going to talk more about this
later on at bonehead of the week because
eric trump was on our bonehead of the
week of course because of his little
crybaby [ __ ] that he did on hannity and
it only plays into this this story and
really honestly i'm really [ __ ]
disappointed that this [ __ ] still isn't
[ __ ] trending on twitter what the
[ __ ] are we doing how in the [ __ ] isn't
this the number one i've been yelling
this for weeks how the [ __ ] isn't this
the number one goddamn story for weeks
and weeks and weeks on end
literally you should be talking about it
at the grocery store with the clerk
that's checking out your [ __ ]
groceries that's how big of a story this
is
way [ __ ] bigger than tom brady
retiring way [ __ ] bigger way more
significant
and it just gets ignored
russia gets a hashtag hillary for prison
trending overnight and bam
we got to do better at this we have to
do better
keep tweeting their [ __ ] names get it
trending i went to search the ivanka
thread and god damns her name has only
been tweeted like 50 times in the last
hour that has to change
we have to make every republican these
[ __ ] criminals
in our messaging we have to tie every
single one of these [ __ ] rather
they want to be or not to these [ __ ]
this criminal organization and these
[ __ ] these [ __ ] mobsters these
cheeto dust mobsters
you think americans are gonna put up
with this [ __ ]
promising promising populist messaging
when these [ __ ] were living off the
state
of new york by defrauding them from tax
dollars
come on and he admitted it out loud even
all the way back in 2016 when he was
debating hillary clinton
me defrauding the state to pay no taxes
makes me smart well we're gonna find out
how smart you are [ __ ] okay let's go to
uh another trending topic that was
trending yesterday i'm very sorry that
it that it stopped trending
jesus
guns
babies i don't know if a lot of people
know why this was trending but it was
trending jesus guns babies when i see
this i'm like oh my god this is going to
be [ __ ] sweet
this is going to be [ __ ] sweet i said
this shouldn't be the tweet but it is
so let's go to the uh let's go to the
search bar here and let's uh let's let's
just type her in
jesus guns babies you guys gotta see
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you have to see this thread this is
[ __ ] wildly uh
just oh candace taylor this stupid trunt
uh
she's running for governor in the state
of georgia and apparently she's running
a primary against the republican there
wu tang for children has the picture
here this woman is running for governor
in georgia her platform is jesus guns
babies
and they're not making this [ __ ] up this
is [ __ ] real jesus guns babies
she paid money to print that [ __ ] on the
side of a bus
have you guys seen the [ __ ] movie the
campaign have you seen that with will
ferrell and zack alphinakis
i don't know what year that was made it
had been like 10 years ago 10 years ago
they made this [ __ ] parody about
campaigns
and they were like oh no way will it
ever be this bad no way will this parody
ever get old uh nope
not even [ __ ] satire anymore it's
reality
jesus guns
babies number one jesus wouldn't have
anything to do with guns you dumb
[ __ ]
and your stance on babies
where it's the life of the mother and
the health of the human being who's
carrying the baby
at stake
and possibly rape an incest i doubt
jesus would be for that
you people really are [ __ ] dumb you
really are [ __ ] tone deaf
wow jesus guns babies and this is only
proof that the tail is wagging the dog
that the ivermectin facebook groups are
determining the messaging of these
campaigns
this is it
jesus
guns
babies
holy actual [ __ ] like they've always had
this message this has always been the
message by the way
it's always been this these three
[ __ ] issues is the issues they've
been pounding since barack obama won in
2008 and they freaked out that a black
dude was president
they've been running on this
jesus guns babies they just never
printed it this way
right
they never even printed this way what's
funny is is they're supposed to be the
freedom party not one word on here about
freedom not one you don't have freedom
from jesus
you don't have freedom from guns and you
definitely don't have the freedom of
your body and your choice
this is supposed to be the [ __ ]
freedom party
you have to be jesus you have to be
christian you have to have guns and be
shot by guns
schools churches
grocery stores walmarts
guns are essential and you must have
them and you must use them on each other
because sanctity of life right because
babies are sanctity of life we want to
make sure that women who are raped
and incest have to carry babies to full
term and also when they're when their
health and their life is at risk they
must die
because babies because that's what jesus
would do get the [ __ ] out of what in the
[ __ ] is wrong with you people
who the [ __ ] is this person
where
what [ __ ] rock
did candace crawl out underneath
whoosh
we definitely got to go down this feed
though this is this is something that we
have to do
amy lynn says is jesus guns babies the
gqp's new version of rock paper scissors
oh
i actually i didn't i did some of this
thread the other day but i wanted this
or yesterday but i wanted to save it uh
eugene says
jesus guns babies really
they have lost their damn minds yes
it's gone
they're they're [ __ ] out again this
has been their argument for the last for
the last 15 years right jesus guns
babies has been their argument right
that that's what it's been
that's that's what the argument has been
the entire time
the problem is the problem is is they've
never actually printed it like that on
the side of a [ __ ] bus
we've gone from jesus saves to
scary larry says we've gone from jesus
saves to jesus guns babies
well i guess that's how white republican
jesus operates right how republican
jesus didn't get trending yesterday i
have no idea
republican jesus definitely should have
been trending and actually we probably
have the meme that everyone shows there
it is and
eugene's got it here of course there's
one that has the wording on it says
something like uh it's a good thing you
were born white
oh my god you just can't make this [ __ ]
up
no no no hold it like this
you can't make this [ __ ] up you really
can't make this [ __ ] [ __ ] up you
can't
it's impossible to parody these people
anymore
like if you go back and watch that movie
the campaign have you guys seen that
movie the campaign with will ferrell and
zach alpinakis like literally you go
watch that movie and this picture is is
supposed to be in that [ __ ] movie
not in reality
and that's
you know this we think this is all bad
news right like this is horrible news
that this should exist this way
and that these people are this [ __ ]
nuts that they would that they would
print this [ __ ] on the side of a bus and
they would make this their [ __ ]
campaign slogan right we think oh well
this is we're we're at the end of our
rope here nope
they're at the end of their rope
right there at the end of their rope
they have nowhere to go but down from
here i mean
how could you [ __ ] out do this
robin you did post a uh um robin's in
here an article
i read part of it newsweek and i said
maybe we should get eric trump back on
the show today wink
so maybe maybe uh if you if you get my
hand uh
so thanks for sending the article i
always like when you guys send me stuff
either tag me or dm me you guys are
always welcome to send me stuff um i
don't know if i'll always get to it but
you can try uh joe says this morning
because uh
jim jordan jim i don't report sex crimes
jordan says make america free again
make america free again
so they keep changing their little
campaign slogan right their little
fascist campaign slogan
br make sure that white dudes are in
power still
in america as if white dudes aren't in
power of everything
white dudes are in charge of everything
you [ __ ]
nothing's changed joe says jim
gym as in gymnasium uh jim tried to
overturn a free and fair election but
okay
oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's he's [ __ ] fascist
man
uh i quote tweet it said free again
[ __ ] turning into socialists so they
want everything to be free they want
everything to be free they really um are
all over with their messaging and this
is what i mean by
with the
jesus guns babies this is what i mean
like they're on their heels
like they they've narrowed down their
messaging so much that they're like well
if you're not christian and you're not
willing to shoot and kill people and
you're not willing to [ __ ] force
people to have babies
then you know because sanctity alive on
all of that yeah right okay
then you're not in our party anymore
they're getting there now let's see what
else do we have um
uh this rachel makes a good point here
you guys know rachel bickoffer
uh just just to remind everyone
new york attorney general tish james
gave up a big opportunity to run for
governor
to deliver justice ice cold to the
trumps i believe this is the one of the
most significant [ __ ] stories
ever
like this is it tish james is going for
the [ __ ] jugular
right
that's what's happening here she's going
for the [ __ ] jugular she's not
[ __ ] around she's not gonna [ __ ]
around
because she knows one thing about the
trump organization right not that it's
just a criminal organization
uh caitlyn tweeted something about the
the civil rights leader george lee you
guys should go check this article out on
apple news by the way
but but the reason why it's so
significant that tisch james is gonna
[ __ ] ice these son of a [ __ ]
the reason why it's so significant that
she's gonna ice the trump organization
the reason why
is because she knows
how important that money laundering
machine is to them right she watched she
tore down [ __ ] the the trump
foundation right she tore it to the
[ __ ] ground made sure those
[ __ ] can't
defraud people by running a fake ass
charity
tore it to the ground she's to tear this
to the ground and their money laundering
machine the thing that makes them appear
appear
rich
is done
keeps them going here's uh here's trump
himself as john walsh that is you guys
know uh john was on our show and he's
appeared on our show a couple times we
interviewed him a while back you can go
watch that episode
but he also appeared as trump that that
episode's also on the youtube channel so
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel that way you guys don't miss any
of these clips
um but here's john's video from
yesterday about trump and his children
may be deposed
trump and his children may be deposed
i could not would not testify i actually
don't even know this guy
i will not will not be deposed the
loyalty ate with these hoes i do not
like these fake news claims i do not
like latisha james
oh thank you john
you can always count on john to give us
a good laugh and clown these son of a
[ __ ] all at the same time fantastic
thank you thank you john um even
i said yesterday even i have an
accountant even i have an accountant
like i have one like mazars
kicks them to the curb even i've got an
accountant i've got one that do
i say what what else do we have here
before we go to the tweety tweets and
trendy trends um midas has their uh
trump crime family they reposted this
video um which i think is a very good
video we'll play that the family is a
criminal enterprise russian mobsters and
corrupt oligarchs use trump's properties
not only to launder vast sums of money
but even as a base of operations for
their criminal activity money tied to
human trafficking and prostitution rings
that's another big one i'll tell you
what it's an organized crime family as
far as i'm concerned according to the
times tonight president trump has a
previously undisclosed bank account in
china that company mysteriously showed a
huge spike in revenue right after trump
was sworn in as president he goes to
china the kid is following like a vacuum
cleaner follows the powers of ivanka
trump her business won trademark
approvals in china the same day she met
the chinese president at her father's
mar-a-lago resort ivanka trump and jared
kushner made at least 82 million dollars
last year while serving as unpaid white
house advisors this guy didn't have a
job but now he's taken in millions and
plenty of it there are new questions
tonight about the eric trump foundation
charity golf events meant to raise money
for children with cancer hundreds of
thousands of dollars went to the trump
family business it's a crime family he's
following his father a crowdfunding
campaign the built section of the
southern border wall this is private
enterprise at its finest the border
walls are cheaper
it's funny they were going to build a
wall on the border
of mexico what about this border the
only thing he built up is a huge bank
account for his son a lot of disgrace
it's a crime family
the crime family
the crime family a bunch of fascists
thank you midas touch for the reposting
that video you know
speaking of border walls and the wall
that they wanted to build there's
another border thing going on i think i
think we might
we might have a a guest with us um that
could give us some insight into
the the
the ottawa border thing let's let's
let's see if we can bring them in here
hey there's germany
how how are you sir
good yeah you i i'm i'm doing wonderful
what what's your name sir uh james
james james uh where are you at james up
here in ottawa uh ottawa okay you look
you look like you're freezing your ass
off yeah it's pretty cold up here but uh
you know we're doing the lord's work
okay what kind of work are you doing for
the lord is this like jesus guns baby
[ __ ]
oh yeah no it's uh anti-job up here yeah
did do what
anti-job up here and it's anti-job in
canada they're they're aunt you guys are
anti-job
no uh anti-anti-job
jab jab
jab okay i get you so what you're saying
is this um this foreign foreign
funded
uh demonstration as it were this
insurrection of the government of canada
uh you guys are doing it what's that
power to the people yeah power to the
which which people you mean the russians
that are helping and the right wingers
from american that are helping you fund
this campaign
you know whoever
whoever whoever whoever would
participate huh yeah whoever is uh
supporting the the local man you know oh
the local man where yeah just you know
anyone who's anti-government yeah who
anyone who's anti-government wants to
overthrow democracies is that right
you know uh
drive a truck right through it yeah
drive a truck right through democracy
yeah yeah
and your name is james you don't have
like a a a different russian handle on
any kind of social media do you james
you are from you're from canada
no no
no you're not from canada no i i'm i'm
from i'm from up here in canada yeah oh
okay so did you drive your truck down do
you have a truck are you a driver or you
just you just cause i know a guy with
the truck
you know a guy with a truck yeah i'm a
businessman no you don't actually you
don't have a truck or you're not a
driver
no no no no no i've uh
i got a pile up here in ottawa that uh
he's got a truck
he's got a truck yeah four four-wheeler
yeah oh he's a four-wheel drive truck or
like a like a uh uh a semi truck no no
no no just a oh just a a pickup truck
yeah oh so so you don't know someone you
don't know someone who actually has a
semi truck that's hauling loads
i mean you know uh
it's all you know your your definition
of a truck yeah i mean trucker just run
run it right through oh okay so so the
idea is to not not actually have any
kind of principle just
um
just you got a truck i got a truck we're
truckers yeah oh so as long as you own a
truck then you're a driver because i own
dirty yeah i own a truck but i i'm not
solidarity against democracy so what do
you hate about democracy really
i just don't want the job you know you
don't want you don't want the jab
it's a jab
yeah
yeah anti-job yeah well you say your
anti your anti-job it sounds like you're
saying your anti-job no yeah anti-job
your anti-job
yeah okay you so you don't want people
to have jobs
anti-job yep yep yeah
okay well james let me ask you because
uh i've seen a lot of videos and
pictures up there and you guys are um
really really having a tough time
raising funds on these uh internet
fundraising things um
that dumb uh
gofundme went
straight straight down okay so what
happened with the gofundme are you did
you give any money or did you have
anybody give any money to the gofundme
and they they had to get it refunded or
how did that work no no
you didn't you didn't give any money oh
no no you're not going to give any money
to the cause right no i'm i'm receiving
the funds yeah oh oh so you're going to
get the money right what is it or is it
for all the uh is it for are the propane
the diesel and the gasoline that is
stored near parliament that looks like
maybe maybe just maybe someone's you
know trying to uh
collect up enough uh you know incendiary
material to do something you know out of
torque no a
a a
um
so so where did you guys leap to because
i know the gofundme got shutter you look
like you're freezing your ass off yeah
it's cold up here in ottawa yeah yeah
yeah what's the temperature there do you
know like
negative 13 celsius yeah
okay okay so so
so once the gofundme got shut down right
what what what kind of app did you guys
have to leap to where did you guys we're
over on the uh the christian donation
site uh gibson go
good
what is it give send go give send go
yeah is that working out for you because
i it sounds like it was frozen like i
know money's coming in money's coming
out you know
oh the money in money out who's gay yeah
money money money and money out
i see i see so what so
so what um what a serious cause tony i
don't know why you're uh why you're
laughing huh yeah well it's what's
serious about it
what do you think is so serious about it
uh making me get the job yeah
making you get a job yeah making me get
a job you don't want a job no
you don't want a job
no no job no job okay so so what is the
aim then to clog up commerce is it to
shut down the economy or is it to
overturn a government it's to show the
people that um we are strong you know
who which people which people
all of them
all all the people where yeah
in the government that the people hold
the power power to the people power to
the people yeah so your anti-job but
power to the people yep no job shut down
the economy right shut it down yeah you
don't want the economy to run no no no
so let me ask you when when when um when
there were shutdowns in canada for covid
were you wanting to shut down the
economy then
uh
no yeah when there were shutdowns for
for the pandemic you know people were
shutting down businesses because no one
was running around
i wasn't uh i wasn't in canada then oh
where were you i i was abroad abroad
where i
that
it's not important tony uh okay so it's
not important where where you may have
been abroad um what kind of
so you're not originally from canada is
what you're saying
uh
no no no no
where are you originally from then james
it's a
another cool region yeah you wouldn't
have another cold or you know
so is it like uh does it remind you of
like siberia or something yeah it's
pretty cold up there too yeah yeah it's
cold in siberia yeah so what's your last
name james what's your last name
um
blakersun bl blakerson yeah that sounds
fake that sounds fake name's blakersun
james blakerson it's probably name yeah
from somewhere like siberia cold
this body was made for cold yeah yeah
yeah sure sure so
anyone with the truck is a trucker let
me understand make sure i understand
this is
right anyone with a truck is trucker
you're for shutting down the economy
because you're anti-job you don't want
people anti-jobs
you don't want people to have jobs and
you definitely don't want commerce you
definitely don't want
um uh democracy it doesn't sound like
you're not for democracy
anti-government understanding
yeah right anti-democracy
yeah you know anti-job the other thing
the other thing i want to bring up
because it was brought up yesterday
uh in in
in parliament in canada believe it or
not
someone was saying that there were
nazi flags being flown and that you guys
were standing with a bunch of nazis
no
no we know we're we're kind people tony
no no no no so you do like the nazi
support or you don't like the nazi
support
i
yeah
yeah so you want nazis to support you
and have the support for the as you say
the people
yep the people
for no jobs anti-democracy
or or or um so no nazi supporter yes
nazi support
no
know what
no for
nothing yeah yeah no
i you tell me i mean i'm i'm
anti-fascist i don't like nazis do you
like nazis
no you don't like nazis no but if they
support the the truckers what if they're
truckers all right would you support
nazi parkers hey hold on
uh tony i gotta go um
yeah okay uh is is
you said putin what uh
you know putin uh
tony uh
yeah it doesn't seem like i'm good at
okay well it looks like uh it looks like
maybe we had a trucker or maybe we
didn't have a trucker um
from from ottawa
uh maybe maybe gable will be back here
in just just a little bit he seemed like
he was a bit he was a bit like gabe
didn't he seem like he was a bit like
gabe okay let's go back to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends oh my
[ __ ] god
oh
this guy this guy uh speaking speaking
of gay beer and we were talking about
the uh
uh
the deposition of the trumps uh this is
a video that gabe did a while back
on uh the deposition of eric trump
of course we see eric's hair is a little
different here but this is eric trump
let's watch this let's begin the
deposition can you say your first and
last name your first and last name oh
you want my name no i i plead the 15th
wait the 15th attendant is about racial
equality and voting no no that's not the
one i want no they're called attendance
it's from the constipation you know the
one that nicholas cage stole i had the
answer written on my hand but now it's
all smeared cause it's all sweaty just
give me a sec i'll get it can you read
what this says i i know it's not the
first or the second attendant mr lawyer
man is my dad mad at me can you just
tell me what ivanka and junior said i'll
say the same thing they said i was the
genius behind everything they're right i
am a genius and i thought of everything
oh um can i get some more oj let's begin
the oh my gosh
oh my gosh
yeah [ __ ]
so we're going to see this story evolve
and i'm not going to shut up about it
i'm going to keep talking about this the
trump deposition story apparently the um
the judge has made sure
that um they will be deposed within 21
days i believe now they have the chance
to appeal we'll see how that works out
um it'll probably be dunked into the
trash i asked a question yesterday would
you rather be hunter biden's laptop or
the trump organization which would you
rather be
which would you rather be
which would you rather be
uh
let's see what else did i want to get to
from yesterday
um
because uh you know today we have uh the
hearing
for stuart rhodes um on the detention um
so the judge is gonna decide today
rather the the detention is going to
just stand the pre-trial detention is
going to stand for stuart rhodes so we
will and we interviewed uh stewart's
estranged son dakota and we got his
reaction to the hearing the other day
we'll probably replay that interview
this afternoon on youtube we'll post
just that interview so you guys can see
that so you can go back and refresh your
memory so you don't have to watch the
entire episode you can just watch that
interview
because as that news breaks for
stewart's uh detention rather they
they will
rather they will uh keep steward in
detention or not then we'll we'll we'll
post that so you guys can refresh your
memory on what dakota said um and it's
possible that because of that we'll
probably bring dakota or maybe uh tasha
stewart rhodes a strange ex-wife we'll
try to get maybe him or her on the show
next week to respond to the decision
because i'm sure as soon as that
decision is made there'll be more
stewart rhodes news being made because
they'll try again and again and again um
let's see we have red coveted red cove
trending at number four um as you know
the new york times has released
uh a story about red coven and how
there's a partisan divide
over covenanting skepticism and what it
is doing is causing
it's causing um people who support
donald trump
to um be it's more deadly coven's more
deadly when you don't have the vaccine
it's a it's a thing that we know already
we've had the vaccine for a while now
like over a year like we're closing in
on a year and three months that uh some
americans have actually had
um the ability to get the coveted
vaccine in this country um it's
overwhelmingly
uh clear that people who have the
vaccine are not being hospitalized and
not dying
near the rate that people are which
that's why we have this big divide and
why there's red coven meaning these
trump districts these heavy republican
states
is where
these people are passing away from covid
still because they're not protecting
themselves
stuart stevens says
on this article from the new york times
about red cobid we talk about
a lot about russian disinformation which
we should but in the last two years
republican fox news disinformation has
resulted in far more unnecessary deaths
now i agree with stuart here but what
why why aren't we talking about how
russian disinformation is republican fox
news different disinformation it's the
same god damn thing it's the same thing
there's no [ __ ] there's no [ __ ]
line between these two
jesus christ they're like putin putin we
love putin we just seen the the trucker
guy
from quote unquote ottawa
in front of the green screen there
we seen we've seen that guy
uh you know
obviously he was russian
but russian disinformation is republican
fox news disinformation
the whole point of all this [ __ ]
chaos to cause this red covet as it were
this politicis politicization of the the
virus itself not just of the vaccine and
the treatments the virus itself
i mean they're they're they claim that
it's fake and then they claim that you
you you you know the vaccine is bad
but then then the vaccine gives you the
virus well the vaccine's bad and the
vaccine the virus is fake they they run
in circles with these things and this
idea that this this canadian border this
truck or trucker thing
in in canada is any kind of real [ __ ]
any kind of real protest against
vaccines you're [ __ ] dumb 90 of the
truckers in canada are vaccinated they
don't have mandates they don't need them
because people are vaccinated when
people get vaccinated
you don't need mandates you don't need
them when the majority of people get
vaccinated
you just you don't have to have because
if everyone if everyone is vaccinated
you have to mandate
everyone because they already are you
got it you get it you get how that works
we're seeing
this russian disinformation which is
republican fox news different
disinformation they're the exact same
thing i'm actually going to quote tweet
here
[Music]
this is the easiest way
equals
[Laughter]
let's do that
see that
real fast boom
there you go stewart okay red coved is
running around the country we got about
10 more minutes and we're going to go to
the bonehead of the week
let's see here um what else do we have
trending today we had red coved uh
[Music]
i'm trying to remember
it's hard to keep track of everything
i wanted to make sure trump's the trump
depositions got in the mix here
uh oh i'm with hillary and hillary for
prison is trending jim hagedorn um he
died
um
gop ish to russia there's liz cheney is
trending
um oh yeah that's good news let's see if
liz cheney is in the top 30 here
kevin mccarthy
let's see
kevin mccarthy decided that liz cheney
is not the person she he wants to
endorse in her race
so he's endorsing her
opponent in the race uh which is um you
know i guess there you go kate says uh
kevin mccarthy backing liz cheney's
opponent is exactly how scared
liz cheney he is yes
um it just shows that they're on their
heels with liz cheney they know um that
she is going to
put the axe down so here here's you guys
know my opinion on liz jenny i don't
think she's any kind of liberal ally
right i mean yeah we don't want to take
the shovel out of her hand while she's
doing the great for trumpism but that's
the reason why she's there on the
committee in the first place
why do you think nancy pelosi would pick
liz cheney as an insurance policy right
she's the insurance policy on the
january 6 select committee just in case
the democrats you know get squishy you
know democrats get squishy about this
kind of stuff sometimes well liz cheney
isn't darth vader jr you don't think
she'll [ __ ] execute trumpism when she
sees the chance to become the [ __ ]
leader of her party of course she will
why do you think kevin mccarthy is now
endorsing
her opponent
because if liz cheney remains as a
congresswoman
and takes her party back and the party
diametrically changes from from backing
this crime family
and these fascists like marjorie taylor
greene jim jordan matt gatz mo brooks
lauren bobert the list goes on and on
and on here
which
jesus christ when people saying that
they want marjorie or the man gats and
jim jordan to be speaker of the house
liz cheney is trying to be the speaker
of the house that's what's happening
here and that's why kevin mccarthy is
backing
her opponent
uh let's see adam kinzinger and what
does adam have to say here when we can't
win rig the game trust trump must be
scared trump moves to close off liz
cheney's political escape hatch
a political article here about it
now
again adam kingsinger is in the same
situation adam isn't actually re-running
because he doesn't want to go against
the trump machine apparently
um but he is gonna try to axe trumpism
and again we won't take the shovel out
of his hand
as he's trying as he's trying to bury
trumpism we won't take the shovel out of
his hand we're 55 minutes into the first
hour let's go back to the trinity trends
and the tweety tweets here
dan patrick the lieutenant governor of
texas
has
let's see occupied democrats have a
texas republican lieutenant governor dan
patrick accidentally sends gop voters
incorrect mailing voting instructions
many republicans now be m excluded from
voting in the upcoming primary
this really is on brand for these folks
right this is why this is why um their
confidence in rigging an election is not
good on them like them trying to rig up
the election trying to make sure that no
matter what happens they win
uh to suppress the vote suppress all the
vote as they
as much as they possibly can to make
sure that they bang up democracy to make
sure that they trick people into voting
or not voting
[ __ ]
god damn
god damn
you're starting to trick your own
goddamn
people your own voters
many republicans now be made excluded
from voting
in the upcoming primary
jesus christ you're suppressing the vote
so much that you're suppressing your own
goddamn vote
it's insanity
oh mj sending me something here on the
dante right case yes um kim potter you
guys want to do the kim potter thread
i'll do that real quick before we go to
break and we come back for the
bonehead of the week um kim potter is
trending number one
uh
here's brooklyn dad to find kim potter
just received 16 months and a thousand
dollar fine for murder of dante wright
it's a [ __ ] disgrace jesus christ
only 16 months good god what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in hell
uh joe says what the [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ]
16 months for murdering
an unarmed black man
and a thousand dollar fine is what the
[ __ ] judge
gave them what a [ __ ] bunch of [ __ ]
can't tell the difference between a
taser and a gun my ass
uh let's see what else is in this thread
um here's joyanne reed kim potter
sentenced
to two years for killing dante wright
and the judge will is giving her all the
sympathy in the world it really sounded
like she was about to give her probation
but this is barely more than that not
even not it basically is probation for
murdering someone
murdering an unarmed person
when you're supposed to this lady was a
trainer
she was supposed to be the person
training other cops
and she couldn't handle this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and now the judge can't handle
sentencing her because oh she's a police
officer the [ __ ] out of here kate says
breaking kim potter minneapolis police
officer who killed dante wright
will only serve two years in prison for
taking someone's life
with negligence this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and this this is this is this is why
people are are upset about law
enforcement and training of law
enforcement
this is why people don't want [ __ ]
cops to have guns and really honestly
cops shouldn't have to have guns there's
other countries in the world where cops
don't carry around guns to [ __ ]
murder people like this
intentionally or unintentionally kill a
[ __ ] unarmed black man
at a traffic stop
for a [ __ ] headlight or a taillight
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
here's the video let's play the video
uh now this has posted this but wu tang
for children has said prosecutors were
seeking more than seven years for kim
potter
she she got a 16-month prison sentence
and a thousand dollar fine for the
murderer dante wright this is not
justice screw this judge let's listen to
the judge
this case is highly unusual
sorry for not being able to hear it
she's talking really quiet
in this court
are distinguishable
she look she even seems like she's
[ __ ] disgraced by her own [ __ ]
words here
doesn't it she's speaking so quietly
into the microphone she can't lean in
and have confidence in what she's saying
get confident [ __ ]
have confidence in your shitty decision
it seems like you really are it seems
like you really really have no
confidence in the decision you're about
to make is not a cop found guilty of
murder
for using his need to pin down a person
for nine and a half minutes
as he gasps
for air
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] to bring george
floyd's name into this trial what the
[ __ ] are you doing
she murdered dante wright put it in your
mouth
this is not a cop found guilty of
manslaughter for intentionally drawing
his firearm
this bullside [ __ ] this [ __ ]
capitulating [ __ ]
this [ __ ] comparing [ __ ]
she [ __ ] shot and killed an unarmed
black man at a traffic stop
and then used the excuse that she
thought she was pulling her taser
instead of her gun
and shooting across his partner and
killing an unarmed woman who
approached his squad
this is a cop
who made a tragic mistake
she drew her file you noticed cop cop
cop cop cop right cop cop cop cop cop
cop cop cop cop
thinking it was a taser
and ended up killing a young man
okay i can't i can't even do it she's
not even confident enough to [ __ ] to
[ __ ] say what the hell she wants
and [ __ ] ridiculous
but you know that that's how that's how
this is going to go
on this [ __ ] thank you wu-tang for
posting that uh video now what a
disgrace this judge is uh looks like we
have gabe back here uh are not back in
and now now he's in he's in he's in here
hey gabe how are you how are you did you
see what what are you saying where am i
back and what you know uh there was a
there was a uh uh look appeared to be a
russian who kind of looked like you um
but you had a russian on the show well
he claimed to be a trucker for the uh
for the uh the ottawa thing but oh i
don't know there was a green screen
yeah i know i know it sounds it sounds
pretty scandalous to me as well
um
uh so what do you think about this kim
potter situation before you get the
bonehead of the week here i have not
even watched it i just i don't okay so
this was the the uh
okay can you give me the tldr i didn't
even see what happened this morning so
what what what is happening is the kim
potter is the police officer that
confused she's right
right and murdered dante wright who was
an unarmed black man
um on a traffic stop routine she's she's
supposed to be a a police uh trainer
she's supposed to train police in these
situations um she didn't know the
trailer
right you're a real not just a shitty
trainer but a shitty police officer
right there's a reason why it's on
each side of the hip not on one side of
the hip right um also the weight's
different but yeah anyway
she was she was actually um
being sentenced this morning
in pure disgrace um the judge sentenced
her to 16 months in prison and a
thousand dollar fine yeah for the murder
of dante wright so dante wright gets
murdered and um she is sentenced to 16
months in prison
and a thousand dollar fine is the uh is
the situation let me pull up the
[ __ ] let me pull up the um the report
here
um hang on just one second here uh
oh
here here's uh well that's i'm trying to
find a video now here's the ap report
um
i'll never be able to forgive you for
what you've stolen from us dante
wright's mother tells the former police
officer kim potter during her sentence
on friday potter was convicted of first
and second degree manslaughter in the
killing of right how did you get like
because i remember when it happened i
was like oh [ __ ] did not expect her to
be convicted now i i don't know how you
go from oh a conviction of first and
second degree manslaughter then going
yeah 16 months and a thousand bucks that
should cover someone's life like what
the [ __ ]
well i mean you know
again i played a little bit of the clip
from the judge right um here giving the
sentence and really the judge didn't
seem very confident in the decision that
she was making it really felt like to me
she was capitulating uh to this person
being a cop she kept talking about a cop
a cop a cop this a cop that um and it
really did seem like is there any way to
appeal i don't know why that i'm not a
lawyer or anything well but is there any
way to appeal a sentence to like that if
it's
well
they can't they can't probably appeal
but um the prosecutor would probably
lose on that ground because she was
convicted and sentenced you know um in
that situation now i mean kim potter's
uh legal team can actually appeal not
only the conviction but the sentence as
well right um so but i mean but i mean
to the like what was the justification
for 16 months and a thousand dollars
well i mean she she wasn't she wasn't a
cop kneeling i mean basically uh she was
making the comparison to george floyd
she wasn't the cop kneeling on a person
um you know
drawing back to uh derek chovin um and
basically comparing the two and saying
oh she was just confused she was just
confused is basically the
the the rhetoric here of course this is
kim potter right
uh let's see if we can find and i'm sure
that once she serves her time and pays
her fine then all of a sudden she'll be
able to move to some other
you know
station right i don't know i don't know
she'll be able to serve um somewhere
else as a police officer here is dante
wright's sister uh diamond let's watch
this let's give the family their due
here
as we gear up for bone in the week let's
let's let's see what she has to say
the defendant should be prosecuted and
sentenced to the highest extent
you can't tell me this was an accident
it's in plain sight she has been a
police officer longer than my brother
has been alive
how come i have to go see my brother in
a metal container just to talk to him
how come i have to pray that my brother
hears me cry out to him
how come my family has to groan and moan
about the loss of a loved one just
because the defendant's actions were
reckless
dante was my brother my blood
someone who was supposed to grow old
with me
how is it that i'm going to see the age
of 21 and he did
so uh she makes a good point there
because really honestly the thing here
is is that this uh this kim potter is
receiving a 16 month sentence for um
rather she murdered or manslaughtered
dante wright she's getting 16 months and
a thousand dollar fine dante wright got
a life sentence um the death penalty so
um you know i think i think that needs
to be taken in in tough consideration
here but
it is it is sad to see that um the
reason why we don't have
uh we can't get past
especially something called qualified
immunity um why we can't work well
so according to bp here he says or they
say uh
no way she'll never work in law
enforcement again she's a victim of
felony now i don't know how this works
in terms of like if that you know
i'm assuming that's true then so i stand
corrected but that doesn't mean that
this person can potter couldn't work in
some sort of law enforcement
job right and potentially i mean
if i'm wrong like they couldn't do some
sort of security job or something like
basically another thing that would uh
put them in a position of
of unnecessary power like before well so
that's a good point i i mean um it is
possible that they could she could work
in not just law enforcement itself but
like a law enforcement group that would
advocate
for law enforcement officers to keep
things like
qualified immunity
inside unions inside police groups
inside police foundations
there's nothing probably preventing her
from working in those places which those
disgraceful [ __ ] would probably
hire this is dante wright's mom let's
listen to what she had to say in court
your honor i hope the defendant is
listening as i speak loud
and clear today
and yes
i refer to her as defendant because i
will not
give her the respect of calling her by
her name
she referred to dante over
and over again as the driver
as if killing him wasn't enough to
dehumanize him
she never once said his name
and for that i'll never be able to
forgive you
and i'll never be able to forgive you
for what you've stolen from us
i hope you're listening
and don't mistake any of my words
because we can't afford the defendant to
make any more mistakes
his name is dante demetrious wright
so the mother of clearly upset there as
she should be losing her son to um
quite the uh mistake of manslaughter um
the last thing on this that i'll mention
is uh
robin brings up a good point here is
like hopefully they'll bring a civil
suit
so right well which which they will have
the right to do not only against her but
against the police department right um
because uh kim potter was acting the
official duty of the police department
um which uh no amount of money will
probably bring back dante right to
uh to his mother kate but katie but um
so let me retweet this here
and give credit um quite the uh
sorry everyone for
having such news to go into the bonehead
of the week but it is so what we're
going to do is we're going to take a
quick break and when we come back um we
will get into the bone heather week so
stay right there
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
[Music]
podcast are you annoyed by masks
infringing on your rights do you wish
you didn't have to comply with biden's
communist mask mandate are you tired of
wearing masks that actually fit your
face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopers mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your drew today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us for bonehead
of the week
we have gabe here not not a russian we
have gabe we have gabe uh nope not a
russian i am a russian i'm an american
did you did you see the did you see the
the quote unquote trucker they claimed
to have no people who owned a truck
um did you see this earlier on the show
were you were you watching no i've been
in meetings this all this morning so oh
okay so so no no no chance that you've
seen the
no i might my internet's been pretty
spotty all day so i've had to like
i can't
i can't like have a a work call and then
do it at the same time oh i get you the
band right so i guess so if i drop off
uh don't like i will come back on the
show just oh okay so if you accidentally
drop off you will possibly come back
yeah okay yeah yeah that's good to know
okay so let's let's start with the bone
of the week of course our contestants
this week actually you know what let's
play the song we gotta play the song
[Music]
[Applause]
i almost forgot that we have to play the
song the q everywhere yeah we got to
keep on
yeah the bonehead of the week so here's
here's the bonus of the week uh rep jim
jordan of course he's he's boneheaded
this morning um he's making his way back
on the list it looks like eric trump and
then dennis oswald um you know we we
talked about dennis yesterday of who
exactly dennis is and that people may
not may or may not have known um who he
was on the bonehead of the week right
right um of course we know our winner
this week is eric trump but let's let's
start with jim jordan because jim jordan
really um
he kind of stepped in it this morning i
don't know if you've seen um no i i like
i said i've been in meetings all morning
so i didn't know okay so so here is uh
here's the jim jordan um uh tweet uh of
course we're gonna make sure that uh
this guy
he says make america free again
make america free again your tweet sucks
dude by the way your [ __ ] tweet sucks
it is horrible [ __ ] your tweet
um so jim jordan make america free again
uh i don't know if just you think he
means like free like as in everything's
free like college should be free
you know housing should be free maybe
you should get free money i don't know
i'm just yeah
i i mean
he chose his words uh
right he didn't say
make america freedom again right right
or like give america it would like give
america freedom again that's right but
right make america free again homie you
just told us all that you want free [ __ ]
right right it does it does seem like
that now why why was this [ __ ]
originally on the bonehead of the week
in the first place because it obviously
he's stepping in it again this morning
but what what the hell was the original
reason so the original reason was
because jim jordan said uh
he didn't want
he said he didn't want people to be
spying on americans
but he was a person who voted to uh
reauthorize
the patriot act
right so he he went in and was like oh
you know stop spy you know it's illegal
to spy on americans or who was spying so
loves so loves patriot act loves the
patriot act unless the patriot act is
used against
right uh seditious fascist uh don't spy
on the president and reveal because the
fear here is obviously like
when he's like uh uh uh um i i i i i i i
it would i uh right it's it's it's that
old video of the kid right right right
right and so but literally he also was
like um i
i do
well i don't know you know it's like how
many times did you talk to president
trump
uh right well how many times did you
talk to him that day well i don't know
exactly
so
uh jim jordan obviously is is [ __ ]
his pants because
uh january 6 committee is getting
records they probably already have
records of jim jordan right because well
they already have the text messages
because they're like oh you illegally
show these text messages or whatever
else the [ __ ] but for jim jordan
he's probably [ __ ] his pants right
now because
he's
i'm sure uh fearful that the patriot act
is going to be used against him
in association with trump and any of
these other seditious people from
january 6. so now he's like oh no i this
is illegal don't do this and it's like
you voted you voted for it right but
here's the thing is they keep saying
this this is the the phrase that they
keep using right they keep saying all
the the
they spied on the president of the
united states yeah no one says
like well here's the thing
even if they did have a re if they had a
reason to spy on the president
shouldn't that ring like shouldn't you
be concerned
that they had a reason right on the
president yeah
like shouldn't this be a concern that
you have not just like oh well like i
mean that that to me is the thing that
like is the most significant like you
actually should be concerned that they
spied on this spread they didn't spy on
obama they didn't spy on bush they
didn't spy on on on clinton they didn't
spy on reagan george h.w bush like they
didn't spy on them why why did that why
would they have to spy on trump this is
a guy who was using private
communications on january 6 as the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup attempt was
happening
and i'm sure we're going to hear more
about that as this ticks on this video
is done by lincoln project uh for it was
posted a couple days ago i think let's
let's listen did you talk to the former
president that day i've talked to the
former president of teen times thousands
i mean i made a thousand dollars
i
i just
it's i mean this response is kind of
like it reminds me of bill clinton when
they're like did you have sexual
relations with you know or like did you
have any sort of uh affair with monica
lewinsky and he's like well it depends
it is
and it's like
we're gonna play that game yeah that was
a stupid response then and it's a
response like i i've talked to the
president up ten times a thousand times
over the presidency okay millions
millions of times he's starting
january 6 how many times
i talked to i
talked to him so much it's hard to tell
i talked to him every morning this is
the same thing as a uh madison cawthorne
you know he said i talked to the
president almost every single day on the
phone he's like a father yeah he's like
a father he's a genius
yeah
oh yeah right yeah what a genius to go
on and say that you're [ __ ] you've
been coordinating with the seditious
criminal that sat at the white house but
coming from a guy who i mean you know
again like all these people birds like a
feather [ __ ] is today's gym jordan's
birthday is it is that the thing oh no
that was 20 hours ago no it's
not okay so it's yesterday jordan
yesterday
was his birthday yesterday we missed his
birthday [ __ ]
[ __ ] i missed it it happens yeah
all right well let's let's go to don't
worry matt gates is coming up may 7th oh
is he okay good good let's let's talk
about the let's talk about the next
bonehead this dennis oswald um because
we kind of discussed him yesterday uh
give give the audience a lowdown of who
this dennis yes
dennis oswald is uh
he is the
uh international olympic committee
um
uh
chair
that works uh in terms of you know
determining if someone should be
can compete or not right here he is in
front of the olympic uh rings here the
flag right all right making those calls
so basically homie here dennis oswald uh
after finding out that uh
the
um the 15 year old russian
uh right which she did really shitty
right she did right she didn't do well
and i also want to specify this too it's
like she's also a victim in this right
like russia has he's 15 years old russia
has a history of [ __ ] doping and
training kids from
very young to be competitively
uh uh olympic athletes right so you know
the figure skater camilla is obviously a
victim here so she's not to blame but
also you know she got stuck in this
storm of she got tested and tested
positive for taking these different
heart medications which are banned and
uh
it's believed to be able to lower your
heart rate so you can be at a
competitive advantage over other people
especially when you're putting your body
at a strenuous right and from what i
understand it's not just one drug it was
several that she yeah yeah there were a
few which then she said oh i took
my grandfather's heart medication which
everyone's like
how did you mistake that right like and
again you know she's probably put up
there and like say this and she's like
okay i'll say it right again again this
is a 15 year old girl who's competing in
uh
olympic athletic competition and i
wouldn't be surprised if the reason that
she didn't do so well after that in this
most recent round where she was you know
potentially able to well not metal but
metal
um
was because of all this like
this stress this new like she became
this huge story so now it's like you
gotta compete and i'm sure you know
coaches and russia and putin and all of
them were like you got to do it you know
um so basically dennis oswalt is on is
on this chair
and of the disciplinary commission and
he said oh you know what uh
um
[Music]
this skater she can compete
um
even though she tests a positive camila
camilla uh veliavia can compete uh even
though she tested positive for these
drugs which called into question what
happened in tokyo which was right
um which which was just a couple years
ago no no no that was this past year
yeah
yeah yeah yeah because you got this
right so you had shikari richardson who
tested positive for smoking marijuana
which makes sense she lost a family
member she was coping
she smoked weed right no big deal again
it's
me she and she actually doesn't get to
compete at all right now she does she
gets to compete and not meddle right she
doesn't get she is not allowed to
compete and so you look at the situation
like what is the difference right you
got a woman who is uh the fastest runner
in her uh in her circuit definitely
would probably middle right would
definitely meddle uh
she smoked marijuana she tested positive
they said she could not compete she
couldn't even compete and not meddle
right then you've got camilla v valeria
or
valleba and uh maybe we should bring the
trucker we could bring the trucker back
on he would probably be able to
pronounce oh that makes sense
uh yeah see like i don't know russian so
i don't know all right right right right
so but but you look at you and it's like
what's the difference right it's one
girl's white and she's like this poor
little 15 year old girl and one is you
know is unfortunately is this a black
athlete shikari richardson and they're
like you can't compete but she can
compete and then dennis oswald's like oh
they're completely different they are
not the same thing it is apples to
oranges
um
you know and and so that's where all
this kind of [ __ ] came in
and also let's just let's just call out
what we said yesterday which is like if
you're smoking marijuana something that
you know affects your lungs right
uh
you're not at an advantage at a sport
that you really need your lungs
for you know
right so it doesn't make any sense why
so it would help you
right it would be an advantage to the
other athletes right it would put you at
a disadvantage assuming that smoking
would would uh negatively impact your
breathing
um in terms of you know
you're running so of course of course
the the reason why dennis underworld
ultimately ended up as bone of the week
not just because of his decision here
but some of the words that he used and
we could go into um some of the video
here but i want to get to not only the
dishonorable mention but also the alpha
cuck of the week because these are these
are important too so let's go to the
dishonorable mention uh lou dobbs um
of course this get this got totally
totally overlooked um in most cases of
what lou dobbs said um why why did he
end up as the bonehead of the week it's
kind of it's kind of gross actually but
you know um we'll go there so why did
lou dobbs end up as the bonehead of the
week do you remember are they yet excuse
me the the dishonorable mention
yeah he's uh what did he say the that
matt gates
speaker of the house it's matt gates and
um the other bonehead candidate jim i
don't report sex crimes jordan
are totally qualified not only qualified
but they should be the speaker of the
house i'm going to try to find some
[ __ ] video here
um
uh but did that
man
yeah really come on man
i i used to watch lou dobbs in college
did you really yeah yeah i used to you
know just to get in you know just get a
perspective i mean he was on cnn and
then he was over to fox and fox canceled
him guys he got cancelled by fox right
right yeah he's the cancer culture over
at fox to cancel him so
you know because he was on fox business
though wasn't he i don't know i don't i
didn't watch it yeah
yeah they were trying to sell him as
some kind of like business thing but he
only talked politics basically so let's
listen to what lou dobbs says here um
and and i don't know what show i think
this is on
matt gatz's little [ __ ] traitor tv
but oh he's uh
kevin mccarthy wants to be speaker uh
when the republicans win in november uh
it's outrageous he is too much of a i'll
be kind
this guy is the one that flies down to
mar-a-lago puts his cheeto dust knee
pads on this guy is endorsing liz
cheney's opponent kevin mccarthy get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
kevin mccarthy is is the [ __ ] a
neo-nazi
placator a capitulator [ __ ] that [ __ ] if
not rhino a middle of the rotor i
personally believe him to be outright a
a rhino uh and
the party needs strength that needs
vision it needs energy vibrancy this guy
can't get on tv so he you know it's it's
like me i can't get on tv so i have my
own show yeah so like matt getz can't
get on tv has his own show and new blood
in leadership what is this why why do
these people have news shows excited
about a speaker jim jordan you bet i
could
why do people in pensacola florida why
do people in pensacola florida think
it's a good idea to have their
representative not working for them but
to [ __ ] be doing
to be doing a tv show i don't know i
mean how long realistically how long do
you think he's on set right like i don't
watch his program but i don't clips but
like this is an actual set right like
he's there he's got lights he's got
someone around the camera someone
running the board i don't this live
stream whatever's going like he's got a
team that he's paying now where is that
money coming from right is it from
the money that he receives as a
lawmaker and then he pays
those people to do
i don't know is that is this where the
taxes that are paying our people are
going to i don't i don't know it's i
can't even understand why people in his
district in florida are like yeah this
is a good idea to have this guy
leadership it's that simple could you be
could you be excited about a speaker jim
jordan oh you bet i could be excited
[Music]
like
it's like oh yeah you know what all the
you know it's like
fascist fascist man
you guys have uh sexual assault
allegations against yourselves and this
guy's like i've got a hard-on for both
of you well in this moment he's like i
got a hard-on for jim jordan and jim
jordan's like i haven't passed a piece
of legislation since the point i entered
into office well why would he he he
can't even wear a jacket he can't even
manage to put a jacket on what why would
it what what would possibly give him the
notion that he would be able to pass i'm
just saying yeah we should have jim
jordan on the show yes absolutely
i'd have [ __ ] matt gatz on the show
absolutely
for sure yeah let's do it i think highly
of you i think you should be in there as
well
oh okay i can't even i can't even that's
[ __ ] gross uh ron posted this lou
dobbs says there was no way kevin
mccarthy should be speaker if the gop
retakes the majority and that only the
brightest conservatives should be
considered like jim jordan and brightest
brightest is the the quote
boy really loose interpretation
it's [ __ ] gross how how
how bright
is the dimmest one in the room right you
know right it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
weird okay let's go to let's go to
because i really want to get to this one
because this oh alpha cuck of the week
alpha cook you know we we
we uh we we went from um from having
three contestants to the moo the news
move so fast and we have such [ __ ] bags
in this country on on the republican
side oh yeah we could probably run a
bonehead of the week every day every day
every [ __ ] day and then it would be
uh i i'm still uh
i still would like to do a uh you know
ncaa march madness come after me i don't
[ __ ] care this is what i'm going to
say right now i want to do a march
madness bracket of bonehead of the week
okay so everyone does their own bracket
to see no no well oh maybe maybe we put
out a bracket you know you determine who
you think is going to win and then each
day we have a separate poll between two
people two people two people like we
have multiple polls that are running at
the same time and then at the end like
we're running
them consistently with the brexit who's
doing all this because uh i will make
this okay i wouldn't be surprised if all
of the people that are on our current
bonehead of the weeks from the past are
going to show up again oh i have so what
i'm saying is like we'll make a bracket
we'll put the names up
you know you know what we'll do we'll
put the names up associated with the
region that they're from that'll make it
easy right oh okay okay and then from
there
we have the bracket people vote do do do
do or whatever make your own bracket if
you want you could submit it and then
every day we're gonna have a live poll
and we're gonna go against each other
for all these weebles and then at the
final end boom
you have the bonehead the the bonehead
madness or whatever you want to call it
yeah what whatever whatever it would be
yeah
i'm down for it if you can figure out
the logistics don't worry man i've been
thinking about this for a while dude
this is everyone else is a prime time
event uh mj says i like your brain gabe
thank you i do too
it's it's all crazy but i like it too um
yeah sometimes it gets me on in a
twisted not you know it with the wigs
and everything but you know we'll we'll
manage to get there so i'm not the only
one okay i'm trying to manage multiple
personalities over here i know well that
is clear the last couple weeks uh let's
go to the alpha cuck of the week
speaking of personality uh charlie kirk
became our uh alpha cuck of the week we
all know why the sexual anarchy is the
reason why uh charlie kirk became the um
alpha cuck of the week africa
yeah
um so we all seen the super bowl last
weekend
where uh i was aroused i i was oh my god
it was um it was like boner city right
right right i i really i really think
what do you what do you what do you
actually think the sexual anarchy was
exactly because i had rachel bitkoffer
on on monday and she's like no it's not
it's nothing to do with sex it's black
people black people are dancing that's
why
you look at the comparison you've got
the [ __ ] dallas cowboy cheerleaders
well any cheerleader squad
they're shaking it they're doing
whatever they're saying college
professional yeah it doesn't matter nba
they have no problem
totally cool do what you want to do boom
but if you're gonna get upset at the
halftime show at dancers dancing and
females doing whatever then you better
have that same energy
right for every sunday when you see
cheerleaders on the side of the field
but they don't they don't give a [ __ ]
and what's the difference it was that
i think there's two things one okay is
that the majority of
uh well the performers on sunday were
black right well outside of one person
pretty much you know eminem but
uh but the other thing
i think is that
uh
on sundays when you do have cheerleaders
and other performers they're on the
sidelines you don't see them a lot you
see some coverage here maybe a
transition before they go to commercial
or a break or whatever right
they're an afterthought in terms of the
game because the game and the players
are the focus
then you've got the super bowl super
bowl halftime you've got a dedicated 20
minute or so
event
where they are the main thing on the
stage no longer players they're often
the they're off in the locker rooms
they're not on tv right now it is these
performers and i think it's a
combination of being like oh they were
black performers versus white performers
and they were given the main stage
versus the sideline and i think it's
those two things combined that people
were like sexual anarchy
well i mean i mean you really you look
at like the just the sex part of the
show like number one snoop dogg was in a
[ __ ] sweatsuit okay yeah he was in a
sweatsuit right now
they were really upset that snoop dogg
smoked weed before which again two
things one in california it is legal
recreational it is legal two it's snoop
dogg this is not right news
even if it wasn't even if it was illegal
he still would have been smoking weed
before he performed
gotta take it boom right and you know
what he did a great show so
it's like it's on it's on brandon so so
here was my response to charlie kirk's
little sexual anarchy i said charlie
kirk wouldn't know sexual anarchy if it
sat on his face
some people some people wanted to add
and wiggle but you know i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna go that far i really
actually think i i i i did this
an injustice i really think if i wanted
to really get this tweet correct it
would have said if she sat on his face
is what um because
charlie kirk definitely would have a
problem
if if it
would have sat on his face right i mean
you could have i bet you no i don't even
know i think you would have to maybe you
go neutral and you say they sat down
there you go that really would have
pissed me because then you'd be like no
gender you know and it's like right dude
calm the [ __ ] down right now it's
bothering you no one wants to even be
associated with you so just shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] charlie kirk and [ __ ] his
sexual anarchy [ __ ] his sexuality
so so let's go to the winner of the
bonehead of the week because here's
here's where our test is again just to
remind everybody we have jim jordan
eric trump and dennis oswald um you know
who shall remain untitled at this point
but he was the the olympic chairman uh
but we had eric trump as the winner of
the bonehead of the week of course um
eric trump the one reason
high-pitched whiny eric trump he was on
the show earlier this week we were so
excited that he was joined us as a guest
on monday yeah he looked looked pretty
fun to give his reaction of the sean
hannity show you know he was on the sean
handy show wanting like a little [ __ ]
about t i just did i'm sure i'm sure he
is uh gonna be back on shows whining
again because you know he's got
he's got his family members now you know
what i you know what maybe maybe um
just maybe i'm gonna maybe i'll uh give
him a buzz here while we're oh yeah
bring him on the show yeah yeah let me
let's play let's play uh the video to
give him his due and his win
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we always get the music going um so
eric eric wins bonehead of the week um
for probably more reasons than one now
because um as we see uh yesterday
speaking of uh eric trump and
depositions that we had him on to
respond about the hand of the interview
um we've seen yesterday that trump all
the trumps all of them
it looks like are we are we losing gabe
gabe are you what's your connection i'm
still here i'm still here oh okay okay
did it just close out
huh did it close out what close out
no
hello yeah hello okay cool i don't know
my video keeps dropping what the [ __ ] no
no you're good you're good you're good
you're you're all right yeah yeah you
are you good are you good yeah you're
good i don't know i told you my internet
is okay well
so i just want to make sure i'm still in
the video okay yeah we're still on we're
still on we're talking about the um and
he's gone again god damn it and he's
done again um
so
why why don't you cut out get your
internet connection uh right there yeah
and then
come on back i'll talk more about the
trump organization
all right so we'll bring gabe back here
bonehead of the week but as you guys
know um the the the uh the let's see if
we can find the interview of uh eric
trump with sean hannity let's just type
in trump
hannity because that was the uh
the interview that he came on the other
day um of course we featured this on
and where he's whining like a little
[ __ ] let's replay this because i think
this is important if the if hunter's
last name was trump yeah that's all
anybody
that's all you talk about
[ __ ]
if we have a two-tier justice system
sure sure
and sean where are the prosecutors right
now you know the same prosecutor the
prosecutors are in court to try to get
your ass and your dad and your [ __ ]
sister and your brother to come be
deposed so they can cut down your
[ __ ] organization and cut down your
company turn off your money laundering
machine that's where they're at for my
father every single day for nothing
right just because they want to
disqualify him because he's clearly the
front runner for 2024. what the [ __ ]
what does 2024 have to do with you guys
being deposed for committing tax fraud
nothing
right where are those prosecutes hillary
rodham clinton is a new york resident
let me just kind of you know break that
down she lives in new york no [ __ ] yeah
we know guess where trump tower is
located it's located on fifth avenue
what the f in new york where this
[ __ ] chucklehead okay so so this is
the this is the thing um that eric trump
uh they're doing and the reason why
they're doing it is because john durham
as you know
um actually filed some [ __ ] thing
about hillary clinton and russians and
russian
opposition material against trump look
every campaign does
opposition material every single one of
them every year um every presidential
campaign does it against their
opposition whether it's in their same
party or in the opposite party they
always do it and really the operation
that hillary clinton and we know this
the operation that hillary clinton the
the the
the information she was seeking was
started by the republicans because
republicans were the opposition of trump
before hillary was now this idea this
you know of course john durham provides
no evidence in these court documents
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to put put news people are saying
people are saying you know you know the
[ __ ] that fox news does and that's what
they're doing here is to try to
perpetuate a complete [ __ ]
disinformation campaign
against hillary clinton and democrats to
distract from the part that he
went that they're going down
they're going down like a fresh cut tree
they're totally [ __ ] screwed totally
screwed eric trump donald trump jr uh
donald trump himself and ivanka they're
completely [ __ ] here and they're gonna
have to be deposed by tis james i doubt
that they're gonna win any kind of
appeal in this case in this matter
actually you know what i text eric trump
it looks like
it looks like we may have
um
eric is that you
hello
are you there eric
yeah can you hear me i can hear you i
can hear you you're here uh you sound
upset
latisha james is coming after my family
okay they came after my dad and my
sister and my brother and now they have
to testify yeah we were just talking
about this we were just talking about
this so yesterday um the news is is that
your your your family seems to be a
little [ __ ] here you had to be deposed
and you you used your fifth amendment
right which the last time you were on
the show you really it didn't seem like
you clearly understood what the fifth
was but that's okay we understand that
uh you know that maybe
you know you're you can't keep up the
speed with things but here's the thing
is it looks like your father your sister
and your brother are going to be forced
to to give a deposition just like you
did do you think their deposition is
going to be the exact same as yours
remember those camping stories that you
and your brother do you think you can
keep your camping story straight
um
i i i i hope so i mean we
i was on the phone with with don last
night and
yeah and he
he said he said it was all good he said
he said
is all good don't have to worry about it
and i was like
okay
okay fine
i hope so
but i also am a little bit jealous and
like envious because
they get to go and do this little tape
session again
you know like this little audition
so you want it so you want to go to be
deposed again yourself is that what
you're saying
uh
yeah
why would you want to go to pose
yourself again you know you know that
you're facing you're facing a situation
where it would tear down your your
family business
because
this is like the most amount of
attention i'm gonna get oh so it's all
about the attention you want the
attention i was on i was on sean hannity
the other night and don't worry i'm
booking
guest spots on shows okay and then like
now i find out that my
my sister and my brother and my dad are
all gonna have to do this thing again
and it was like
why not me
why not me like it's like leticia james
just doesn't like me it's like i went
there and i did my audition tape and she
just didn't like it so she didn't do a
callback
no no eric it's not an audition it's not
an addition it's a deposition
a definition
okay we're gonna you have to say your
name and you have to say where you're
from and they have to say who you
represented by
so i was like uh my name is eric trump
and i'm represented by my lawyer and
right i live in mar-a-lago and new york
you live in mar-a-lag mar-a-lago is not
new york is it no i'm saying i live in
mar-a-lago and new york oh you know so i
i'm i'm a local hire in florida and in
new york
local hire as in a role for a movie this
is not this is not an audition it's a
deposition no a deposition she said they
said we're gonna use this tape and we're
gonna send it to our directors and we're
gonna review what we said
no no not not directors prosecutors
prosecutors
do you know what prosecutors i was in
the room tony i pretty sure i know what
they said oh okay so so you think this
is an audition tape for a movie that the
that some directors are going to be
doing that's what they said do you know
what that movie is it's going to be a
big moment in history they said we're
gonna there's a movie there's gonna be a
documentary uh you know this is gonna be
used as as uh
for what we do when it comes to you know
uh uh making it
so is don you talked to don jr last
night uh-huh and and then don's your
brother he's your older brother uh-huh
your dear your dear older brother uh-huh
so and you re you really like you get
lit up in the face when we talk about
your brother don you really like don
junior yeah and remember last time when
i was here i told you about how i was
like because like i'm like super excited
like if i get cast in this movie you
know that leticia james like and it's
like she is a hard casting director okay
but she said she was like we're gonna
take this you know we spent hours on
this you know you you we you know i we
got what we wanted you know and and uh
but what i'm saying is like uh my
brother
my brother don like i go over there and
i direct his little videos he makes for
his channel you know um you're talking
you're talking about the facebook videos
where he gets all uh strung out on on
cocaine and decides it's a good idea to
post social media post that yeah the
ones the ones where you know you know
he's got his little logo in the corner
you know it's getting says like it's
it's he's he says like the logo is um
it it has to like
uh
come off as like
fancy he's like it's gotta look great
way better than anything joe biden would
do that's what he said
so so so he wants to make sure that his
logo is better than joe but i don't
think joe biden has a logo by the way
like
that's what my brother said okay right
right right
i just wanna i just i just
i just
i just wanna get on tv again okay well
the good news is the good news is eric
you you are on live you're on live right
now
and we're online we're on live this is
live on youtube twitter and twitch and i
have i have some news for you speaking
of winning awards
um i know you probably like to win
awards right now we don't have like a
special ribbon cutting where you have
like a six foot uh
golden uh scissors and i really don't
have a trophy to give you but we
actually did a vote this week and we do
a vote every week on the tony michaels
podcast it's uh it's at tony michael's
pod and it's bonehead of the week and
here was the contestants this week it
was jim jordan
it was dennis oswald and you you were
one of our contestants that's right
oh my god and there was a there was a
vote there was a vote for bonehead of
the week that you were on the good news
is eric the really good news here is
that you actually won bonehead oh
this is amazing
oh my god
i can't wait to show my brother and i
could show it to my dad and i could be
like look dad i actually accomplished
something you know because all the other
times like whenever i'd be like dad look
i did well he would yell at me and then
i would end up crying and stuff you know
and be really
kind of
emotionally damaging to me
if i'm being honest and
so now i can take him like look who's
the bonehead of the week that's right
you're the bonehead of the week eric
look who it is i am the bonehead of the
week you are the bonehead of the week
and um maybe maybe in the future as you
do more bone-headed [ __ ]
maybe you can be on the bonehead of the
week again there is a really good
opportunity for you to win this not just
once but on multiple occasions eric
whoa
so
so
so bonehead
is a good thing or it's a bad thing
um
well that that is a good question that
is a good question rather it's a good
thing or a bad thing but let me play the
video that shows you being the winner
and you can decide
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that was me
that that was you that was me i was like
yep right
that was me i was like speed racing i
was like
so
do you like to play with pullback cars
and stuff when yeah i got a train set
and everything yo do you really say yeah
yeah yeah i got a train set and
everything yeah did you like the
confetti we really want to go all out
here
michael's great
great well i'm i'm so happy that you're
the bone end of the week i'm really
excited that you uh that you're excited
about being the bonehead yeah so is it
good or is it bad it is definitely a
good thing that you're the bonehead of
the week
it might not be good for you but it is
good for us
wait what
well you know do you know what bonehead
means
eric eric eric it's okay eric eric it's
okay it's okay i'm sorry you won
no no you won
you won you won you eric eric
eric
get all of yourself get hold of yourself
you mean funny
get ahold of yourself get older yourself
get older yourself
uh everyone loves you way more than your
father does i don't even know if your
father is who you are
it's all right it's right eric get over
yourself there's a few more questions
i'd like to ask you if you can get ahold
of yourself so i'd like to ask you about
your sister's stance because we talked
about don jr i would like to talk to
talk to you about your sister stance we
got a little bit more time left here
of what um what her stance is on her
deposition and what she's gonna be do
you have does she have her story
straight is her story the same story
that you told in the audition
you know that you were talking about
earlier the audition tape that you were
talking about earlier i told my sister
what i said and then she said
i'm gonna [ __ ] you over
and
what
what what is that what does that mean
what is that i don't even know
i don't even know i was just like ivanka
uh this is what i told them so we make
sure that we both get parts of this
movie you know and then she said
it's my [ __ ] part
i i don't even know
you think your sister is trying to steal
steal your part in this movie with the
audition now of course the audience
knows that this is a deposition not an
audition but you're confused a little
bit here and that's why you're probably
the bonehead of the week
it's like
i
i don't even know tony it's like
you know it's just like
i i just wanted to be in this movie so i
thought i did a really good job but you
know they were like eric eric it's not
it's not a movie it's not it's real life
it's not realistic
right i know i know say my line again
and then my lawyer was like say the same
thing they're gonna we're gonna do it
what was your line what was your line
uh
i said the fifth amendment
so you just said fifth amendment that's
all you would say yeah my lawyer was
like hey listen they're gonna ask you a
question and then they're gonna say a
line and then you're going to say a line
and your line is
fifth amendment okay the fifth i pleaded
the fifth you gave me some alt like
alternative lines okay so what were some
of those alternative lines that you had
uh
it was i need to consult with my lawyer
okay i plead the fifth yeah
um can you repeat the question okay
and um the last one
was
uh
can you remember well i kind of like
improvised it i was like
is my dad mad at me
okay well speaking of your dad and ben
being mad at you have you talked to him
about what he's gonna have to do being
deposed is he
i tried calling him i tried calling him
all yesterday when the news broke i was
like oh my god dad you're going to be
you're going to audition for this movie
too and you're going in for leticia
james she's a real hard ass no no no no
no no aaron eric it's not it's not a
movie it's not it's it's just movie they
had a camera they were filming me right
they said this is an audition tape no no
it's a deposition tape for court for the
prosecutors to to use this evidence i
was there for like six hours that was a
real that was a real hollywood audition
no no no
hollywood auditions i don't think take
that long i don't think they did
i don't know they gave me juice and they
gave me crackers yeah you said apple
juice last time and yeah an apple juice
last time yeah yeah with this so
[Laughter]
so so you haven't been able to get a
hold of your father then
no i'm assuming it's because he is
preparing for his audition
that he has to do for leticia james so
do you do you think he'll take the fifth
the same way you took the fifth or do
you think he'll he'll talk his way into
a crime again well i mean i don't know
if we're going for like the same role so
i don't know why he'd be saying the same
things as me you know i don't know why
he would be using the same lines you
know
well
eric i i think you are very very
confused but um i appreciate you coming
on and accepting the award of bonehead
of the week we really
we love it is you we love having you on
the bonehead of the week poll i know the
audience loves to vote for you and
they love voting for you eric let's
let's do this one more time just for you
since you love the videos so much let's
give you your one last view here um and
i'm sure we'll probably have you on in
weeks to come because you will probably
do some more bone-headed [ __ ] but let's
play your videos
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you really you really kicked jim
jordan's ass there eric he really kicked
his ass i was like i was like here he
comes
and
[Music]
and then the other guy at the bottom
whoever he is he was like
he's like
like he like barely even made it out of
the gate
and then jim jordan was like
and i was like
yeah i'm glad i'm glad you're excited
that you won eric um congratulations on
being the bone end of the week uh it's
well deserved um i'm sure you'll be back
on the poll soon soon enough can i can i
can i get footage of this interview for
like my reel you absolutely can have it
for your deposition reel when you're
when you're auditioning for uh an orange
jumpsuit somewhere wherever it may be
whether it's in the state of new york um
or in other states or in the federal
districts um thank you eric for joining
us for bonehead of the week and um and
congratulations on your win truly truly
you are a [ __ ] bonehead and my
audience loves that you're a bonehead
because they love uh clowning the [ __ ]
out of you thank you i am a bonehead
bye tony bye
thank you thank you everybody for
joining bone of the week we'll be right
back after the song then stick with us
[Music]
[Applause]
all right bone end of the week we had
eric trump there uh come in to accept
the award of bonehead of the week you've
seen him earlier on the show earlier
this week and then eric come to accept
his bone end of the week award oh my god
um it seems like eric trump is probably
going to make more and more appearances
here and it seems that way possibly
thank you for joining us today and all
this week and remember next week
next week
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 center right here
on youtube twitter twitch don't forget
to subscribe to the youtube channel um
that is very important do all the things
that you're supposed to do like i'm
supposed to go down there and click the
[ __ ] and click this thing and click that
thing and subscribe also go to
uh the twitter page at tonymichaelspod
follow us there the bonehead of the week
poll will be there as well we have some
great interviews coming next week some
really great interviews um
we're working on some news breaking
stuff oh it looks like gabe gabe's
signal finally came back gabe did you
get your signal back here hell jesus
i've been you yeah you missed you missed
eric trump on the uh bone end of the
week he came in accepted yeah he came
and accepted his award come on man i was
on the phone with spectrum yeah well
internet sucks out here yeah the
internet's uh it sounds like you need to
get that situation figured out but no
eric came and accepted his award i
texted him and boomy was here
boomy was he dude you got it
i know i know i know well next time next
time maybe you can interview him you
know if you if you get a chance if your
internet connection is good maybe i'll
let you talk to him next time you know
you can do a back and forth or something
like that um but
so we have some exciting interviews
coming next week yeah um uh we we're
doing we're doing a short little
interview today with a with a democratic
candidate down in texas
which is a really cool i'm excited to
talk to this candidate now because of
who they are and what they're
accomplishing down there um so we'll be
playing that next week um also we have a
really special interview on saturday um
it sounds like it has to do with maybe
that russian trucker that was on earlier
and some of those things and i know i
know you've kind of arranged this
interview i'm excited about it i'm
excited to hear what exactly is said but
hopefully we'll play that next week as
well we're supposed to record that
tomorrow um
it has to do with some of the ottawa
trucker thing right is that correct
without giving too much away yeah it's
got a yep it's got to do with the
that whole i mean like i feel like
anything more information would be given
away basically it's about the the
trucker freedom convoy in ottawa okay
good good good so so we'll uh but it's
not the ram ranch resistance side no no
no no no no no okay good good yeah um
everyone loves the ram ranch yeah and
maybe maybe maybe we'll bring that up in
the interview to get their reaction to
the ranch thing so remember that on
saturday and hopefully hopefully we'll
have time to play trivia with those
guests but i'm sure they have so much
information that we might yeah we might
just be like skipping for this one well
just because there there is a lot of
really good information that they have
so that's going to be important so we'll
probably play that next week like
tuesday or something we'll probably have
that ready sometime tuesday wednesday
something like that we'll also have that
candidate um we also have an interview
that's in the can that i want to tell
everyone about um and i don't know how
far because there's a lot of footage
there i know how far you are but we had
walter masterson a couple weeks ago that
we interviewed um and he talks about and
he and
and the reason why i bring this up is
because he's actually been at the
trucker convoy yeah
yeah he was up there also with uh
anthony who lives right in canada yeah
and i i actually um i've had anthony on
the show um a while back actually last
year actually um so
i know anthony and i know walter and and
we interviewed walter before he went to
this trucker thing right he talks about
all the trump rallies he talks about the
january 6 insurrection while he was
there
so we had that interview maybe we'll
play that next week as well we got a lot
of stuff on our plate next week yeah but
look forward to the walter masterson
interview to come uh soon go check out
our interviews from this week not just
eric trump but also rachel bitkoffer we
also interviewed jojo from jurors we've
had a lot of really good interviews
this past week and we have really good
ones coming up we have a special one in
march so you guys need to subscribe to
the youtube channel don't miss anything
um you know
definitely go to thetonymichaels.com
go to uh gabe's website as well i think
gabe i think i'm gonna put your stuff on
on mine too so we get uh so that way
they can find out yeah you know they can
find everything but go follow gabe at i
am gabe sanchez follow me at the tony
michaels because you are not going to
want to miss this next couple months we
are going to have some big interviews
we're talking about some big people and
i think i think um even um maybe
breaking some news like we broke the
news with tasha adams yeah which is the
i think i think this saturday story is
going to break sometimes i think it
could i think it could because because
i'll i'll tell you i think eve as much
as we like to clown these people we like
to take this stuff seriously we like to
give you guys uh good solid interviews
an interview that no one else is gonna
do cnn um msnbc or any kind of serious
journalist because we're not serious
here you take us seriously not literally
right but but uh we try to have a
conversation with someone that has an
open conversation right we don't want to
we don't want to lead them to a certain
direction or that sort of thing so stay
tuned for all those interviews because
we have some really special ones coming
up and uh go back and watch all of our
past ones subscribe to the youtube
channel again next week all week
every single weekday even on president's
day on monday we're not going to take
the [ __ ] day off we're right here
noon eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch and until monday
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking